A third alternative is what is called a big
flip. In the big flip, what we are doing
is we are bringing down half the nodes at
once. So in other words, the service is available
at 50% of the full capacity. So you can see that with a big flip, half the nodes
are down. So we have reduced the server capacity,
the total DQ available by 50% for u units
of time. And the total upgrade is going to
last 2 times u because we have partitioned the
entire server capacity in two halves, and upgrading one
half, upgrading the second half for 2 times u
time units we're not going to have full capacity. And
during this 2 times U time unit we get
the service at 50% capacity, and at the end
of this it is back up to full capacity.
So these are the three different choices that
you've got, the fast reboot where the upgrade
time for the entire service is just equal
to the upgrade time for a single node. But
here, we don't have the service available for
any of the users for that period of
time, and this might be a, a good
strategy for services that can exploit the diurnal property
of user community. Rolling upgrade is the more common
one, where what we are doing is we are upgrading
the servers one at a time but it's going
to take a long time especially when you're talking about
data centers having thousands and thousands of processors. Rolling
upgrade is going to take a long time and it
might be done in batches for instance instead of being
exactly one at a time. And the extreme of that
rolling upgrade is this big flip where we are
saying we'll bring down 50% of the nodes, upgrade
them, and then turn them back on, and then
do the upgrade for the remaining 50%. So in the
third case, in the big flip, the service is
always available, but at 50% capacity for a certain duration
of time. But there is no way to hide
the DQ loss. And you'll see that the DQ loss,
which is shown by the area of this
shaded rectangle in each one of these cases, the
area in the shaded rectangle is exactly the
same. In other words, the DQ loss is the
same for all three strategies, and it is
the DQ loss of an individual node, the upgrade
time for an individual node, and the number of
servers, n, that you have in your server farm.
That's the total DQ loss for online evolution, and
all that these different strategies are saying is, as a
system administrator, you have a choice on how you want
to dish out the DQ loss. And make it apparent
and not apparent to the user community. In this
case, it's going to be apparent to the entire user
community that there is upgrade going on. In this case,
different segments of the user community are going to notice
that the service has become unavailable for a
short duration of time. And here it's sort of
in between these two extremes and that half
the user community may see a service being unavailable
for some amount of time. So, in other
words, using the DQ principle, maintenance and upgrades are
controlled failures that can be handled by the administrator
of a system service. So what we are seeing
through this concept of DQ is a way by which a system
developer and a system administrator can work together in figuring out how
to architect the system in terms of how the data should be
partitioned or replicated and how the system should
fine-tune the service by looking at the instantaneous offered
load and tuning whether to keep the yield the same or the harvest the same,
knowing that DQ is a constant and the
server is getting saturated. And finally, when service
has to evolve once again, the system administrator
can make an informed decision on how to
do this online evolution by controlling the DQ
loss that is experienced by the user community
at any point of time.